Hi, and welcome to AlphaBits.
AlphaBits is an outlet for our inquisitive minds.
We can't stop experimenting with new technology, and
we wanna share what we're playing with with
you. We're your hosts, Brian and David. Hi.
I'm David, defender of the Rawkode Academy. I'm
a perpetual learner, always playing with new cool
tools that I'm gonna share with you as
part of this podcast. And I'm Brian. I'm
a developer advocate at Amazon,
and I love all the shiny new toys
in tech.
It's kind of my passion is is testing
out the new stuff and,
seeing what's cool. So I will start the
demo joy
by sharing my terminal.
So this is,
and there's no graphical interface to this. It
it's only a login shell
on my laptop.
And if I do something like l s
v l k,
you can see the USB key that it's
booted off of,
and then the physical disk
that have been claimed as,
persistence
data spots for,
Lightwhale's
Docker container. So it it keeps,
Docker images on one partition and persistent
data on another. And so when I reboot,
it will still boot off of the USB
key, but all of my Docker container stuff
is
in it's on the physical disk. It's a
really neat way to do things. So let's
just look.
Again, this is BusyBox, so there aren't a
ton of things on the host when the
the operating system itself is tiny. And I
have a Docker Compose directory here.
And inside that are all of the things
that I run internally for my my own
bits. I've got Caddy as my reverse proxy.
I've got Coder for coding
environments, Paperless NGX for document storage,
syncing, and vault warden for pass password sharing.
So if I c d into one of
those, like, caddy
and show the
Docker Compose file,
you can see that
we've got
my Docker storage set to home op persist.
So any data that is in the container
will be in a completely different directory on
the host, which I can just back up,
which I do just back up.
And I can just do doctor compose stuff
like normal.
And you can see the logs for caddy.
You know, nothing exciting is going on there.
So this is actually really exciting because it's
it's the lowest footprint you can get for
a
hosting environment. I mean, there's really nothing
nothing you could do that's smaller than this
operating system.
And the the point is that you don't
really have any system updates to do because
you've got a stable kernel. You've got a
stable version of Docker.
And so the only maintenance you need to
worry about is keeping your containers backed up
properly.
So it's super exciting.
And I've been using it for about a
month now. I worked with,
the developer
to, get NVMe support because the scripts originally
didn't support NVMe disks.
So I submitted an issue, and and he
got that fixed up
later. So this is, it's called Lightwell. And
if you just Google search for Lightwell,
you can find it. Super awesome. So that's
demo one. Let's go to demo two.
So this is,
I'm testing this in a virtual machine on
my host. So this is just a a
KBM virtual machine
with another instance of
Bluefin.
So let's log in as me,
and let's show off the interesting bits here.
So if we cat let's see. Password.
You can see that I've got
three extra users created here.
Locked user, confined user, and full user. And
those are demo users
to show the different
levels of isolation that you can get per
container. So locked user doesn't have any access
to the local disk. The only thing that
that user can do is touch the storage
in the Docker volume that's assigned the container
volume that's assigned.
Confined user has access to their own directory,
their home directory,
but can't do, anything else much at all.
And then full user has access
to, becoming sudo
and doing root things
and also has persistent disk storage. So if
I change to root here
Let's go to Var Home.
You can see the three users, the full
year,
and I'll show you how we set this
up. So if we go into config
containers
system d,
there is a container definition file. This is
a quad lit definition. This is a Hat
labeled,
docker compose,
layered on system d.
So let's PI that.
And what we could see is
it's a standard system d unit. Before it
starts, it's going to make
the user's data persistence directory.
It's gonna run the image container image for
the word toolbox,
name it podman s h,
and this is important. Remap users inside and
outside the container because podman's rootless.
So this is using
c groups to
maintain
the
user ID and group inside the container.
I have
SC Linux
disabled
because I don't have it working yet, I
don't know how. So that's a study issue
for me.
Running it means it's gonna run-in system d,
and we're gonna keep the data directory
at the home,
and the capital z is a SE Linux
labeling
attribute.
Workdir's home directory,
and what it's gonna do is exec sleep
infinity. So as soon as this person
logs in,
this the container will start,
and the this will just keep the container
running while the person's logged in. I also
set the network level to host so I
don't have
NAT and contained networking.
So that's all I have to do for
this user. And then
if you look at the key password,
you can see that the user's login shell
is set to user bin,
podman s h.
So that's it. We we defined a container
that's gonna be this this user's login shell,
and
I can do So how do you configure
the difference between the full user and the
contained user? Like, where is that configured? So
that is that's actually all in the container
file we just looked at.
So the podman
arcs and the volume, you would change those
to,
to different levels. Like, we look at,
go to the docs,
documentation,
search for podman s h.
But this one page, by the way, is
all of the documentation that exists, one man
page. So, they've got some examples on here
that show the various levels of lockdown. So
the first one, the locked u,
has absolutely no access to the host OS,
and it drops all capabilities, no new privileges.
You know, this is a completely locked down
and secure user environment,
which is, you know, good and bad. You're
not gonna get a lot done in there,
but,
you're not gonna get a lot done in
there. So that's good. Then the confined user
uses,
remap users. So it keeps the user ID,
and it has access,
same as you would on the host. So
you can have data stored in local disk
that appears as your home directory there. And
then the final one,
and this is the example
that I'm roughly based on, but I can't
get all of this SELinux stuff to work
because SELinux
is a mystery
to everyone.
So this one is
also running in a container, but it has,
the ability to
escalate to root,
and it can run containers
inside the container. So it can
it can run nested containers,
which I haven't got working yet either.
So let's let's try
to
SSH
as that user. So we'll SSH
full view at localhost.
Set the key,
type in a password,
and it blows up. It broke.
Don't know why.
Let's find out.
Why?
Maybe try a different user.
Oh, there you go. Oh, there we go.
I got one that time. So who am
I?
I'm full u.
And if I c v to my home,
I'm at var home full u. Let's
l s. So there's a file called some
file. Let's
I don't even know if the I exists.
Alright. So now if I s u,
You can see that,
some file is not here.
It's actually in the data directory.
So when I am inside the container environment,
my home is this data directory
because that's where we set it up in
the,
the container quadlet definition.
So I can do,
some pretty cool stuff,
like
change the
container.
Oops.
Too fast. I don't have the keyboard here.
So right now, it's running Fedora toolbox, but
what if I wanted to run a completely
different container? I don't know if there is
an Ubuntu toolbox in that registry. Let's
let's look at my host
and get a good example. So
there's an Ubuntu example we can use. Well,
let me.
Alright. So we'll change this from a
Fedora
to Ubuntu.
And now if I log out,
log back in.
So do you not need to restart the
system d service? Nope. Because it's it's really
a a
daemon it's a login shell. So it it
container stops running when you log out and
starts running when you log back in. Okay.
So now I could cat
OS release.
Oh, yeah. And you can see I'm running
Ubuntu now instead of Fedora.
Neat. So if if I had it set
up, I could do apt update, apt install
things.
That's one of the sticky parts right now
is that
the user management is on the host operating
system,
and it doesn't doesn't copy in like this
Etsy shadow.
So I have to reset my username and
or my user password
in order to get root access. And I
have scripts to do that right now. I'm
hoping there's some way I can change the
init system to do that automatically,
and then this will become a pretty neat
tool.
So that is my demo. Completely
contained user environments in containers.
And the last bit to show you is,
oops,
is that this is not just at the
level of terminals.
If I log out,
I can log in as that user
and get a desktop environment
where everything is still contained.
So the terminal
and
and I've got my Oh. Ubuntu environment,
but I'm clearly in my Fedora Gnome
window here. So pretty slick. I'm I'm excited
to see where I can take this.
I'm sure I can abuse it a lot.
Question is, will it be practical and useful
to do so? So that's my demo for
today.
Very cool. Alright. So you should be able
to see my web browser. This is Infisical
Cloud.
So everything is open source to remember, but
I have set a few things up just
for the demo today. So I have an
organization called Rawkode Academy where I could invite
people.
I have a project called Rawkode Cloud. And
if we explore that, we can see the
different environments that have been configured. Now these
are arbitrary. They don't need to be dev
staging and prod, but, you know, that's what
they are out of the box. You're welcome
to tweak it. What's nice is that we
have these two properties, cloud dev name and
password. We can see that they're set in
dev, but not in the staging and production.
So, you know, we could go into here
and start to provide those values that we
wanted,
or we could just explore dev and we
can just click and see what the values
are. So from a perspective of managing secrets,
you just
add stuff in the web UI. One, three,
a, b, c,
and then click save.
These are all very much like get and
that you can well, I guess on the
cloud version, we'd need to host it ourselves.
But you can see the differences
there's a complete log of the changes.
We got the other log over here. So
now one of the things I like about
the cloud version
is that it has all of these integrations.
So one of my pet peeves just so
you know, it's nice to keep secrets in
one location, but you always need them and
third party services like GitHub actions. Right? We
wanna be able to get our secrets in
one place over there without having to do,
like, a dual commit and update them in
multiple places.
With this, you can just click integrate with
GitHub.
It'll actually still approve the app, and you
can tell it to sync this project to
a repository secrets in GitHub.
And then whenever anything changes here, it automatically
updates GitHub for you and they get the
new credential,
which is also a nice touch.
So let's drop down to my CLI
where we can run-in Physical run,
and I could run a print end where
we have one environment variable called cloud dev
name.
And this will automatically be injected, and then
it prints out here. We can also do
the same for password.
So the idea being our workflow
becomes,
you know, NPM
run dev or whatever the command is or,
you know, for the Go developers, go run
main.go,
etcetera.
And all you need to do is prefix
it with this Infisical run,
and your environment is automatically injected for you,
which is pretty cool.
There are a couple more things that you
can do. So if we do Infisical help,
they have a scan command, which will actually
scan your get history and any files in
the local directory to see if any of
your secrets have been committed now or even
in the past and give you a way
to kind of,
you know, you just have to know that
it's been committed to kinda clean up and
rebase and get rid of all the bad
stuff at some point. So the
way that this works,
I ran Infisical run without specifying, like, the
project or the environment or anything, but everything
is just inside the JSON file. Okay. So
this workspace ID is actually my Rawkode cloud
project,
and I've set the default environment to be
staging.
And you can tweak that to your parts
content. Oh, nice. And you can change environment
by changing
to a different Git branch too. That's like
Yeah. So you can have it. Like, if
you're on the main branch, then, you know,
it's probably gonna use your production environment if
you wanted it to. And if you're on
the dev branch or non main branch, then
it can use another environment. So there are
lots of little things you can set up
like that.
The
the whole web interface, it's quite nice. You
know, it's got things that I haven't seen
in similar solutions like this folder
approach. So, like, from here, you can actually
say that you want to create a new
folder and these work like a
let's call this sub project. Like a namespace?
Yeah. So we can now come into the
sub project.
There
we go. And we can now add more
secrets at a different level. So we get
a password, b b c one two three,
and save.
So you can give people access. So it's
kinda like a security boundary. I could say
that you only have access to the subproject
secrets, whereas I would have access to all
of the So
it you know, if you got a model
repository, for instance, this would be a good
way to do it. Or if you just
want to separate concerns, maybe you've got, like,
AWS secrets, Cloudflare secrets, and you wanna just
contain them all slightly separately,
then the folders are are quite a nice
way of doing that.
And they also implement one of my favorite
features
from Doppler, which is secrets referencing.
So if we come into the subproject,
we could say
root secret,
and then that can actually be a reference.
I'm not gonna be able to remember how
to do this now.
Let's see.
It's
something like
secret, and it takes a full path
within this project. So we could say something
like that.
So you can reference up and down the
stack. You cannot reference across project, which is
something that Doppler does quite well.
But I think I kinda prefer the approach
that Infisical have taken with it.
So
I just think it's a cool project.
You know, full disclosure, it's not something that
I'm running
for any real project
yet,
but I just think it's something that I
may use for secrets management moving forward.
So I'm still fully in the one password
camp right now, and I use the one
password still live in a very similar fashion.
But I do like the integrations that they
offer to sync to GitHub, to Cloudflare.
In fact, if we look at the integrations,
it's pretty vast. Right? So you can go
to AWS secrets manager, CircleCI,
GitHub, fly dot I o, which I'm starting
to use a bit more. Cloudflare pages, I
use
I use an awful lot.
And then, obviously, Terraform cloud and stuff. So
it's just it's just new. And
the last thing I'll say,
these framework integrations are fantastic too. So, like,
even if you don't want to run Infisical
run on your CLI, you can actually just
have the JavaScript SDK pull secret out within
the code if you're Oh, wow.
And as long as you have a service
account token to speak to Infisical,
then it will just work. So that's another
pretty neat way of doing it as well.
I wonder if there's a quick code sample
I could show here. Where's
and React should be enough.
Nope.
Framework integration.
I'll go next. Nope.
Nodeto.net.
Am I not seeing something here?
Where's the code?
Never mind. There is a complete SDK. That's
awesome. I just put the Cal node there.
I feel like I have to find it
there. There we go. I was on it
recently.
So
yeah. So you can just create your client,
and they have service account tokens so you
don't have to pretend to be a person.
And then you just say, hey. Get my
secret, and then it's available in your application.
So, yeah, really cool project. And then
hopefully, get more stuff or get some stuff
moved on to it at some point. I
love it. I'm 100% gonna self host some
of this. Yeah. I believe the requirements are
just it's a Node JS TypeScript application.
It requires a database, which is MongoDB.
And as long as you satisfy both of
those, then you have a fully
managed secrets environment that you can run anywhere.
They actually have a starter thing.
So if you come to Infisical
on GitHub, they have like a one click
deploy to EC two and Digital Ocean as
well. Wow. Very cool. Nice.
And they can self host with Docker Compose,
so I'm gonna go put it on my
Lightwhale box.
Yeah. I was I was considering doing a
Docker Compose up as part of the demo
and I thought, no, that's not important. Just
show the product. So there we go. Very
sweet. Good demos today.
Yeah. I think I'm gonna have to go
a bit more alpha for the next one
considering you showed two things that have barely
any documentation.
You've got things with docs and, you know,
Docker Compose files and, you know, that way
too beta for me.
Let's get get a little deeper here.
It's still a 0.9
release. So, you know, it's it's still very
early but the you know, I think that
project's been around about five months now
And I think they're funded. I think it
took off when people seen it and as
they're now trying to build a business around
it. So best of luck to them. Yeah.
I love this. This is great. Gonna make
some. Alright. Awesome. Good week. Well, that's I
like this one. Yeah.
See you next week. Cheers. If you wanna
hear why we showed off these tools, check
out the podcast available at alphabets.fm.
Until next week, see you soon.